I'm 26 years old I'm currently an
undercover detective I've recently been
told that I'm being promoted to sergeant
over our departments Investigations
Division
I've been the youngest person to hold
that position in our departments history
all the guys I'll be in charge of our
much older some in their late 40s how do
i as a younger leader lead them how do
you demand and earn respect from an
older group I'm ready for the job and
know what the job entails but I'm
nervous to lead a group of nine people
that are all older than me so I'm I've
answered this question over and over
again and I'm gonna do a quick job of it
here just because people may not they
have gone back and listen to all the
other podcasts but you have listened the
answer is always the same and it's
always the same whether you're a young
person leading old persons whether
you're an old person leading young
people whether you're a woman leading
men a men leading man leading women
whether you're coming in from a
different department into a new
department that you don't know anybody
whether you're going into a thing that
you don't have experience it's like all
the same basically what it is you're
going into a leadership position yeah
that's what it is be humble listen take
advice build relationships keep your ego
in check also that one of the reasons I
pulled the did pull this question I was
like how do you demand respect well the
answer is you don't demand respect and
if you don't if you do demand respect
you'll get anything but respect from
people mm-hmm so so get that out of your
head you earn respect and how do you
earn respect you respect them in this
case you respect their experience you
respect their knowledge you respect it
they've been doing it for a long time
you have respect for it and when you
show respect for them they're gonna
respect you back now none of this means
be passive hmm right this doesn't mean
cower down no you you still have to lead
you still have to step up but it does
mean be humble be open-minded be
proactive listen ask questions ask for
opinions de-centralized all aspects of
operations including the planning which
we already talked about
and then with all those things set a
high standard and then the final and
most important well I don't know it's
equally important I'd say work harder
than everyone else and expect nothing in
return
mm-hmm that's it yeah that's it you're
the boss you better be it you better be
at work before everyone and you better
be leaving work after everyone and
that's how you develop a reputation of
being a hard worker and being a hard
worker in its own right
Garner's respect from most people
there's there's a fraction of losers
that are like Oh Ecco he works so much
it's it's so lame like no like cuz I'm
making them look bad or something yeah
yeah yeah yeah like there's a small
fraction of people that that might think
that way but but no you work hard you
you put in the time you put in the
effort you study you read what you're
supposed to read you get the
professional knowledge that you're
supposed to get you don't impose that on
people yeah you have it because you're
your book knowledge when you start off
in this situation your book knowledge
isn't as strong as the experienced guys
in this case you know in the in the law
enforcement the guys that have been in
the streets they know stuff that you
don't know yeah so you study what you
can but you keep an open mind so you can
listen to what their experience says
yeah don't impose on them when you say
don't impose it on them does that mean
don't impose them like make them it's
like them echo section for two alpha of
the documents says that we're supposed
to use this methodology when we do this
yeah you should know that methodology
you should understand why that
methodology is important but if you say
hey jogo we don't do it that way and
here's why I shouldn't I'm telling you
by the book it's by the book now if it's
by the book because it's there's an
ethical reason okay well then that makes
sense but it's by the book because
that's what the book says
by the book yeah yeah or you know the
guy who's like who works extra hard but
he kind of in a way throws it in
everyone's face how are you that that's
that's an important thing it's a very
important piece don't you don't step on
people's toes with us
yeah that's wrong yeah don't do that
yeah check